[Musik]
einen wunderschönen abend zu die
richtigen fragen heute mit einem pflicht
duell einem duell zwischen zwei männern
die jeweils auf der einen und auf der
anderen seite stehen und zwar mit dem
fdp
bundestagsvize wolfgang kubicki und dem
oberbürgermeister von tübingen boris
palmer der heute angekündigt hat auch
wieder anzutreten allerdings dann als
parteiloser bevor wir über das thema
impfpflicht sprechen möchte ich aber
einmal nach london schauen bilder die
zumindest mich ein bisschen neidisch
gemacht haben denn da kann man sehen wie
die menschen wieder feiern da gibt es
keine masken mehr in den clubs sowieso
nicht und auch sonst überall london sind
die korona wegen beck masken weg partys
wieder da und das obwohl die situation
ganz generell was impfquote angeht nicht
wirklich wahnsinnig viel besser aussieht
als in deutschland herr kubicki wenn sie
diese bilder sehen ab wann fallen bei
uns endlich die maßnahmen
ich kann die glaskugel schauen diese
frage kann ich nicht wirklich sinnvoll
beantworten aber ich vermute mal dass
wir in die karl lauterbach dem
bundesminister glauben wollen in zehn
tagen spätestens die spitze der
mikrowelle erreicht haben danach geht es
dann wieder bergab und dann vermute ich
dass wir zu den beginnenden frühjahr
vielleicht mit dem mars ende las dazu
übergehen die eigner vielleicht eher als
in anderen ländern eine vielzahl
maßnahme wieder feiern zu lassen dazu
gehört für mich in erster linie zwei
flüsse in das tor aus weil wir dagegen
vorgehen zu schützen die 2g maßnahmen im
einzelhandel die ja auch geologisch
keinen sinn machen solange wir dort mit
masken tragen uns viel besser soll
jessica ich glaube mit dem märz
angemessen das der fall sind da noch
masken weg
etwas später noch über masken sind hier
für den selbstschutz
ideale maßnahmen wenn wir alle sp 200 zu
tragen das ist mir mittlerweile
forschung erwiesen infizieren
jahreswechsel sei nicht schützen und das
wird wahrscheinlich die letzte maßnahme
seien die feiern wird in innenräumen
draus mache keinen sinn aber in der
größenordnung oster und denkt immer
werden wir in den jahren davor auch in
einer gewissen normalität des lebens
zurückgehen herr palmer ich will ihnen
einmal eine grafik zeigen was die
impfquote angeht der vergleich zwischen
deutschland dänemark und großbritannien
und dort sieht man dass unsere quote im
vergleich zu großbritannien zumindest
was die zweitimpfung angeht sogar besser
aussieht das gleiche bild nun wenn wir
jetzt sehen dass in england in
großbritannien wieder alles fällt und
bei uns gar nichts passiert und sie
sagen wir brauchen die impfpflicht ganz
dringend die allgemeine impfpflicht
warum bitteschön
herunter eins darf ich vorwiegend doch
sagen ich werde nicht als parteiloser
kandidat antreten weil ich weiterhin
mitglied der grünen wien so als
parteiunabhängiger kandidat für den
unterschied lege ich doch großen wert zu
ihrer frage da fehlt immer noch der
anteil der genesenen denn die genesenen
sind so gut vor infektionen geschützt
wie die geimpften und großbritannien hat
halt sehr sehr viel mehr infektionen
zugelassen während der pandemie deswegen
sehr viel mehr genießen muss man
eigentlich auf die geimpften oben
draufsetzen und es scheint so als ob
großbritannien mittlerweile soviel
grundimmunisierung erreicht hat dass man
keine massnahmen braucht genau dahin
will ich möchte wieder kubicki das ist
möglichst bald keine corona
schutzmaßnahmen mehr benötigt ich kann
diese freiheits angriffe nur ganz schwer
ertragen und meiner meinung nach kann es
uns dabei helfen diese
grundimmunisierung herzustellen indem
wir eine impfpflicht für die
risikogruppe einstellen also die über 50
jährigen denn nur in diesem
altersbereich sind die menschen die
intensivbetten brauchen wegen corona und
nur wegen des schutzes der
intensivstation machen wäre überhaupt
die ganzen maßnahmen wenn es sicher ist
brauchen wir sie nicht mehr und ich
glaube dass das ein guter weg wäre die
maßnahme loszubekommen japan erklären
sie uns einmal viele menschen die ihren
kurs verfolgt haben im letzten zwei
jahren als krone begonnen hat die haben
gefeiert und hat gesagt sie sind ein
freiheitskämpfer sie sind derjenige der
alles versucht dass die freiheit zurück
kommt und vor allem sind sie gegen
heftige einschränkungen und jetzt sind
ausgerechnet sie einer der vorkämpfer
der impfpflicht wie passt das zusammen
das sieht nur nach einem widerspruch aus
ich habe immer in der pandemie gesagt
wir müssen die maßnahmen wählen die den
geringsten schaden anrichten und die
besten effekte erzielen das war zu
anfang der partie mieterschutz der
risikogruppe der altenheime anstatt die
schulen zuzumachen das war dann später
das testen einzuführen und damit kultur
und einzelhandel zu ermöglichen statt
alles in den walk down zu schicken und
jetzt ist es nach meiner überzeugung die
impfung denn eins muss man auch sagen
hätten wir nicht diese impfquote würden
uns derzeit laufen die geimpften
infizieren sich wie die ungeimpften mit
mikro aber sie werden hat fast nie so
krank dass sie ins krankenhaus mussten
wer also jetzt ungeimpft ist der
profitiert davon dass so viele geimpfte
gibt uns sehr wenn ich diesen ganzen
winter wieder im lockdown und ich
respektiere ja die kraft der fdp die ist
stark aber ich bin sehr sicher herr
lauterbach würde uns diesen doktor und
einen weiteren winter dann auch zumuten
wenn wir so hohe zahlen hätten wenn wir
keinen impfschutz hätten deswegen ist es
schon so wer jetzt dass ich selber die
impfung ablehnt der profitiert letztlich
davon dass andere die impfung gemacht
herr kubicki sind sie enttäuscht von
boris palmer wenn man sie vor einem jahr
noch zusammen eingeladen hat dann haben
sich gemeinsam gekämpft und jetzt sagen
sie wir brauchen diese pflicht nicht und
der palmer sagt wir brauchen sie
unbedingt also ich bin von der jurist
war natürlich enttäuscht sondern
kalkulieren was seine entscheidung auch
als partei- und direkt zu kandidieren
weder der stadt noch den gemeinwesen
hätte es mit angestellten werde eine
persönlichkeit ich suche unterstützt
wird in der eigenen stadt nur die
parteiinterne
rangeleien will ich mal sagen nicht
wieder kandidiert an so fern herzlich
und sozialgeschichte ich bin ich ein tor
stand aber ich wunderlich einer dass sie
auch dieser datenlage ja gar nicht haben
zu suchen entscheidungen zu treffen wir
wissen in deutschland überhaupt nicht
geld bereits genesen ist wir haben keine
untersuchungen vorgenommen obwohl dass
er mehrfach müssen vorgeschlagen wurde
beim aussuchen konnte festzustellen ob
die ich vielleicht auch alles
spezifiziert worden und genesen sind die
genese start unserer bevölkerung kennen
dich und um das neue auf den punkt zu
bringen das licht angeht wir wissen und
das verlies unstreitig dass eine
impfpflicht omikron nicht mehr wirksam
bekämpfen kann weil sie einfach zu spät
kommen ist einen doch die welle bei uns
hinweggehen momentan ja auch mehrere
hunderttausend infektion prozent das
wären alles dann auch gewesen sein wir
haben vor allem das ist für mich ganz
wichtig weil ich das argument
nachvollziehen kann diejenigen mit durch
impfungen zu schützen über liegen dann
auch die intensivstation kommen wo der
schwere verläufe haben wir haben bei den
über 60 jährigen eine impfquote von 90%
wohin soll die noch gesteigert werden
und das ist wie gesagt auch ein phänomen
seit zwei jahren haben wir keine
ausreichenden daten ist dann immer
wieder entscheidung aufgrund von
vermutungen getroffen und wir sehen
steht york scheint ist unmittelbarer
nachbar von denen markt werden die
gleichen voraussetzungen mit denen mag
was die impfquoten in den verschiedenen
altersgruppen angeht dass die dänen ist
sichert sich selbst erlauben wieder zur
normalität zurückzukehren ab 14 uhr als
auch übermorgen und wir nach wie vor so
tun als müssten die menschen in angst
und schrecken versetzen
besucher und auch das noch dazu kommen
kann ich glaube nicht dass das eine
impfpflicht weiterbringen wird vor allen
dingen weil das problem sein wird dass
viele menschen unabhängig von der frage
ob sie für richtig halten oder nicht
dieser in pflicht passive griechen
würden ein letzter satz sie haben ja mal
erklären sie können auch knopf drücken
und dann rund 80.000 menschen den
typischen angeschrieben und was machen
sie denn 40.000 überhaupt nicht
reagieren dass er das nächste problem
sie werden erleben wie die mit dazu
aufgerufen überhaupt nicht zu reagieren
und haben sie anfangs problem dass sie
starten sondern seien leistungsfähiger
wird empfahl sie haben ja sogar schon
mal von beugehaft gesprochen was die
möglichkeiten der angeht ja weil wir
wollen sie dagegen wenn die 40.000 nicht
kommen wie wolfgang kubicki sagt ja da
ist mir ganz wichtig der kontext also
mir hat jemand erzählt die impfung gegen
therapie und deshalb faschistoid eine
impfpflicht zu fordern habe ich einfach
zurückgeschrieben wegen solcher ignoranz
ist die impfpflicht besonders nötig von
mir aus bis zur beugehaft es war dahin
gesagt wir wissen auch alle dass richter
entscheiden also natürlich jetzt dahin
gar nicht aber ich bin in vielen punkten
mit herrn kubicki einigen wir nochmal
die unterschiede herausarbeiten also
herr kubicki völlig eigentlich mit denen
es ist schlimm dass wir in deutschland
keine vernünftigen daten haben deswegen
brauchen wir es eigentlich meine
digitalisierungs offiziere da sitzen
aber die haben ja vor palma hat die
haben wir hatten sie wollen dann wäre
ich trotzdem ja ich will das erklären
ich sage wir brauchen in zukunft
vernünftige daten da hat er recht aber
nur wenn man keine daten hat kann man
sich ja die entscheidung nicht ersparen
da muss man halt mit
wahrscheinlichkeiten recht und meine
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung sagt nach
wie vor ist es so dass die impfung zu 80
bis 90 prozent davor schützt auf einer
intensivstation zu müssen gilt auch für
umgekommen und was sie sagen das ist nur
zehn prozent der über 60 jährigen sind
ist gerade im grund für die impfpflicht
es sind nämlich nur noch zweieinhalb
millionen menschen so wenige wie wir
impfen müssen um wirklich sicher zu sein
dass es keine lockdown mehr braucht als
auch im nächsten winter keine
intensivstation gefährdet sind weil wir
dann die grundimmunisierung der gesamten
risikogruppe geschafft hätten und diese
zweieinhalb millionen menschen die
erreichen da jetzt offensichtlich nur
noch durch eine pflicht und da bin ich
persönlich überzeugt dass das nicht so
laufen dass sich niemand zurück meldet
sondern dass die allermeisten menschen
so wie ich ticke solange es meine
freiheit ist nämlich die war aber wenn
es eine pflicht gibt die der bundestag
beschlossen hat dann natürlich die
selbst dann wenn ich nicht ganz mit ihr
einverstanden sind nur wenige menschen
in unserer gesellschaft die pflichten so
ablehnen dass ich sie auch wenn sie
demokratisch beschlossen wurden einfach
nicht erfüllen wollen aber wie
gerechtfertigt ist dass herr heimat
dieser freiheits eingriff die freiheit
zu sagen ich will mir nicht etwas in den
armen rahmen lassen die muss es doch
auch geben insbesondere wenn wir uns
anschauen das omikron eben nicht
besonders gefährlich ist insbesondere
wenn wir uns anschauen ich kann da von
mir selbst sprechen ich habe mich
mittlerweile schon zwei mal infiziert
und bin genesen trotz booster impfung
also und jetzt will man mir erzählen das
soll ja alles vor möglichen ganz
wahnsinnig gefährliche nächsten wellen
schützen das ist doch alles nicht mehr
so gegeben wie uns dass die politik
erzählt hat am anfang nein es hat sich
was geändert ohne grund ist eine flucht
mutationen und man kann sich wieder
anstecken das ist ganz klar aber das
schützt vor der schweren erkrankung
bleibt es ist genauso klar und jetzt ist
es letztlich eine abwägung eine
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung ich sage mir
ist das risiko dass die nächste welle im
nächsten winter die wird kommen uns
wieder zu locken massnahmen zwingt dich
als freiheits eingriffs schlimmer finde
als die pflicht zur impfung weil dadurch
mehr noch was gutes damit ist dieses
risiko zu groß und ich möchte dass
deswegen die risikogruppe durchgängig
geimpft ist dann können wir sicher sein
im nächsten
hat ja schon etwas wichtiges gesagt
nämlich dass die risikogruppe über 60
zum ganz ganz großen teil geimpft ist
also wer aber trotzdem macht die immer
noch mehr als die hälfte der
intensivpatienten aus diese kleine
gruppe von zehn prozent der risikogruppe
ist die hälfte intensivpatienten und
wenn wir die jetzt schützen würde dann
hätten wir die krankenhäuser sicher ich
gehe auch gerne zur kopie geht dann
können sie übernehmen das ist eine
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung es kann auch
sein dass wir im nächsten winter keine
schlimme welle haben und dass das alles
geht ohne im pflicht es kann ich auch
nicht wissen aber ich würde da gerne auf
der sicheren seite sein weil ich diese
ganzen corona maßnahmen möglich nicht
mehr im nächsten winter sehen möchte ich
möchte dass das alles aufhört alles weg
alle maßnahmen weg und es bleibt nur
eine regel für alle nämlich geimpft sein
sie hat sich
herr kubicki verso mit mich stört dass
man so war zunächst die
gegenüberstellung es gibt nur ins licht
oder lockt darum ich halte das alter für
für unverantwortlich also kann ich da
noch sagen darf so zu argumentieren dass
die anderen möglichkeiten gibt mit
infektionen umzugehen zunächst mal
wissen wie doch gar nicht von den
zweieinhalb millionen menschen von denen
sie sagen sie seien gebe es nicht über
ihnen große anteil bereits genesen ist
das infektionsgeschehen der sich alle
über 60-jährigen sich infizieren auch
kleines krankenhaus müssen wurde die
station das sind zudem stimmt das nicht
mehr ganz so auch auf der
intensivstation eine menge älterer
menschen die aber schon seit geraumer
zeit im jahr kaufen neu zu studieren was
besonders frappant ist ist die tatsache
dass
dass wir obwohl wir es wohl
infektionszahlen haben bei der
mikrowelle wir kaum ein zulauf haben zu
den krankenhäusern ich kann das nicht
flächendeckend sagen weil
bedauerlicherweise des recker diese
zahlen nicht erlebt auch aus berlin
wissen wir bescheid von der charité dass
80 prozent gehen die mit chroma getestet
bord sind gar keine koma versetzt und
dann bei der einlieferung ins
krankenhaus wegen der greifenden uhr
getestet worden sind und dann doch aus
diesen ist das ist corona infektion das
wird dann richtig der das stetige
holstein dass sie auch bei uns mal den
zu laufen denn die krankenhäuser
tatsächlich kein anwachsen da vor allem
nicht auf die intensivstation
was wir jetzt an nicht erwarten ist
insofern ist das bild ähnlich wer sich
mit micon ansteckt auch wenn er über 60
gelandet über kurz oder lang auf der
intensivstation ein zweiter ist der
verlauf ist momentan dankenswerterweise
so dass sich diese bi oder überlastung
ist besonders systems nicht eingestellt
hat ihm das nicht wegen der
koma-patientin möglicherweise wegen der
quarantäne die korona infizierte
behandelt hat oder sich selbst infiziert
wird dann eingehen muss noch einmal ich
warne dringend davor nach zwei jahren
kann denn je weiter mit angst und mit
mit befürchtungen zur arbeit statt mit
genauer analyse der fakten und
entsprechend reagieren und agieren zu
können herr palmer warum machen sie uns
so viel angst tue ich nicht also da bin
ich ganz bei herrn kubicki in dieser
partie wurde viel zu viel mit panik auch
weiter du zählst du damit wurde aber
jeder warum erkälteter realität an die
die es jetzt gibt nämlich dass omikron
milder ist dass es keine schweren
verläufe mehr gibt dass die impfquote
bei den älteren schon sehr sehr gut ist
dass im vergleich zu ländern wie
großbritannien dänemark deutschland
nicht schlecht da steht die brauchen das
auch nicht also warum nicht
weil ich angst mache sondern weil ich
mathematiker benutzten szenarien rechne
es kann sein dass herr kuki gerächt hat
und wir auch ohne weitere impfungen
keinen lockdown mehr benötigen das ist
im reich des möglichen bestreite ich gar
nicht aber wir wissen es nicht und es
kann im nächsten winter eine neue
mutation kommen die wieder etwas mehr
intensiv patient aber wie lange das dann
gehen dann kommt die nächste
motivation die hinter nächste genau das
ist mein argument für die impfpflicht da
wir bisher bei allen mutationen immer
gesehen haben der schutz für die
krankenhäuser bleibt erhalten nur das
schutz vor infektionen geht verloren
möchte ich im nächsten winter dann nicht
wieder diskussion haben jetzt brauche
eine impfpflicht die wieder zu spät
kommt bei um den grund kommt sie zu spät
ich habe deswegen im november gefordert
man sollte die impfpflicht machen um auf
der sicheren seite zu sein mit dieser
wollen geht es mir um die versicherung
gegen weitere lockdown und dieser schutz
vor schweren verläufen auch bei mutation
ist eine versicherung davor dass es im
nächsten winter wieder los aber leicht
fällt vielleicht dieses wirklich das mag
sein aber ich hätte lieber sicher aber
diese versicherung ist es ja eben genau
nicht herr palmer zumindest wenn man
sich die daten jetzt anschaut sie können
ja nicht versichern dass es eine
mutation gibt im frühjahr oder im
nächsten winter die abgedeckt ist dann
mit den impfstoffen die wir momentan
haben wir wissen ja gar nicht ob die
impfstoffe überhaupt dann wirklich für
weitere mutationen die richtigen sind
aber was wir wissen obwohl wir schon
damit konnten fast ist alphabet durch
haben hat bei jeder mutation bisher der
impfstoff die schweren verläufe
verhindert das nennt man
grundimmunisierung es gibt sehr hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das auch im
nächsten winter wenn die nächste
mutation kommt so bleibt herr kubicki
ich will nochmal darüber sprechen wie
das ganze überhaupt ja wenn ich wollte
sagen also auch das ist ein fremming
dass ich nicht teilen kann zunächst
einmal wissen wir ebenfalls in meinem
alter dass diese angeht und
immunisierung nach zwölf wochen
nachlässt deshalb nicht weil die
israelis nach halle
virologen und ines darüber verdiente
sich nachdenken ob nicht personen wie
ich mit einem weiterhin 60 alle drei
monate gegend fahren muss um diese um
diese immunisierung aufrecht zu halten
zudem wissen wir mittlerweile das habe
ich besonders dass die genesenen an den
höheren zuschuss haben es gibt auf und
zwar nirgendwo auf der welt genesen auf
intensivstationen oder mitschülern
todesfällen gegensatz dazu dass es
intensive stationen des auch mit
todesfällen selbst gebastelte
mittlerweile gibt was man vielleicht mit
der frage beschäftigen sollte ob diese
buchung auf dauer gegen zeitz und
problemen befreien können dass sie
zurecht beschreiben zudem bin ich zwar
kein mathematiker aber ich würde jetzt
nicht auf die idee kommen zu sagen wir
müssen die grippeschutzimpfung
verpflichten machen weil wir nicht
wissen können ob ich im nächsten jahr
ein böses grippevirus wie 2017 2018 über
uns herein fällt man kann als deshalb
sagen das sei ja touristen man kann
nicht mit einer vermutung dass künftig
vielleicht an den bösen mutanten kommt
eine impfpflicht mit einem impfstoff den
wir dagegen noch gar nicht habe mit der
behauptung wir hätten ja als ich eine
grundimmunisierung nach der impfung ich
würde ihn zu stimmen wenn die
veränderung eine sterile immunität
herbeiführen würde wie das bei pocking
und maß an der zeit ist und man
reinigung dann zwei oder drei impfungen
ist sein leben lang geschützter vor und
das kann auch dazu beitragen dass die
was rauszuholen was ja bei der woche
gelungen ist das ist bei fast ob bisher
nicht erfüllt wie ich vernommen habe und
fast einigen führenden deutschen
theologen werden wir bei diesen
zoonotischen viren überhaupt nie dazu
kommen sie auch wirklich folglich
aushalten zu können und es ist die
pflicht für mich der letzte aufschrei
derjenigen die immer erklärt haben man
kann sich frei impfen wir lernen nutzen
unser normales leben zurückkehren ohne
dass das bisher und umgesetzt worden ist
und mein persönliches problem dass
einmal das will ich noch mal sagen und
ich liebe diesen staaten über alles
vertraglich die demokratie mit zähnen
und klauen mein problem ist dass wenn
wir jetzt die impfquoten erhöhen und
feststellen dass das auch nichts nützt
um die freiheit mehr bei zu führen von
denen sie gesprochen haben dann wird das
vertrauen in die politischen status
träge und ihnen einen wesentlichen teil
der wissenschaft wirklich fundamental
erschüttert werden das ist etwas was wir
riesenprobleme bereitet momentan ihr
diskussion auch da hätte ich einen
logischen einwand nehmen wir an wir
hätten die impfpflicht würden sie
umsetzen ich glaube das geht und danach
würde sich herausstellen dass es immer
noch schwierigkeiten gibt die
intensivstation zu betreiben dann geht
es meiner meinung nach nur eine logische
konsequenz dann haben wir keine anderen
möglichkeiten und zu schützen wir können
nicht noch 20 jahre lang lockt downs
machen dann müssen wir einfach sehr viel
mehr geld für intensivstationen
bereitstellen dass die irgendwann so
leistungsfähig sind auch mit corona
klarzukommen das kann sich heute schon
das könnte oder müsste halt nicht so
schnell also sollen wir sogar aber die
nach der pflicht kommt nichts mehr die
impfpflicht logisch die letzte maßnahme
dann ist schluss sondern zwar bedeutend
sein aufhöre wo ich irgendwas zu japan
das bedeutet ja nimmer so weit ich weiß
nicht ob ich wenn ich mich impfen lasse
im nächsten winter noch geschützt bin
das habe ich ja schon mal gesprochen
bedeutet auch nicht wir müssen wirklich
unterscheiden der schutz vor infektionen
der nimmt nach zwei monaten deutlich ab
vater kopie geht zurecht erwähnt die
grundimmunisierung heißt der schutz vor
schweren verlauf nach allem was wir
wissen bleibt der sehr lange erhalten
hat alle mutationen bisher erfasst dann
lass uns noch mal drüber sprechen wie
sie das ganze jetzt kontrollieren wollen
man erlebt ganz viel widerstand bereits
die menschen sagen das darf doch nicht
wahr sein erst wurde uns gesagt zwei
impfungen jetzt drei impfungen jetzt
wird schon über viel gesprochen und vor
allem diejenigen die sich bis jetzt
nicht haben impfen lassen es ist ja
tatsächlich ein harter kern der das
nicht will also wie konkret sollte der
staat dann gegen diese menschen vorgehen
aus ihrer sicht also welche im flick
befürworte ich über 50-jährige weil das
die risikogruppe ist und zwei maximal
drei info bin ich mehr und da geht es
nicht um dann im fokus sondern nur um
die grundimmunisierung dann muss schluss
sein und dann reden wir von zweieinhalb
bis drei millionen menschen hat haben
kopie gibt zu recht darauf hingewiesen
ich wollen sie alle kontrollieren und da
bin ich überzeugt wenn wir die
anschreiben dann werden wir feststellen
dass die allermeisten rechts bei der
staatsbürger sind und eine pflicht
erfüllen und ihr könnt doch nicht von
dem ziemlich kleinen teil derjenigen die
sagen mich interessiert nicht was der
bundestag beschließt abhängig machen was
wir vom was ist wenn der bundestag
beschließt die impfpflicht kommt schon
ab 18 dann würde ich sagen es geht zu
weit aber auch dann hat der bundestag
das beschlossen und ich glaube wenn das
beschlossen hat würde jacobi gibt hinaus
habe ich sagen pflichten sind zu
erfüllen da kann man nicht sagen das
interessiert mich nicht ist das so herr
kubicki wenn diejenigen sich durchsetzen
würden und der bundestag der insel so
lange so lange gesetze gelten gelten sie
für alle und man soll die
sinnvollerweise auch befolgen ist ein
gericht kommt zu der erkenntnis dass
diese entscheidung steht in der gerade
verfassungswidrig war dann muss man das
liegt nicht mehr tun aber ich bin nicht
ganz so optimistisch dass genau diese
frage angeht weil etwas anderes ist das
tagesgeschäft geben bei und wieder
abbezahlen wurde er an franz stoff und
seinen eigenen körper zu bekommen und
wir erleben ja seit drei monaten also
das sind drei monate dass der versuch
von uns der politik über 2g regeln die
ungeimpften quasi vom gesellschaftlichen
leben auszuschließen auch nicht läufen
hatte sich nicht gekannt zu erhöhen das
bedeutet es geht einfach um mehr als nur
um die frage leichter titel mein körper
ja oder nein es sind nicht nur
querdenker und rechtsradikale eine
vielzahl von wünschen aus völlig
unterschiedlichen gründen manchmal
zwischen der garten nur angst vor an
einer solchen impfung weiß nicht wissen
was das wird was uns dass probleme
bereiten würde bei der konkreten
umsetzung
wir haben ein weiteres problem das sich
nochmal ansprechen sie müssen im prinzip
bei jedem den sie jetzt gegen seinen
willen impfen weil der ja eigentlich
gefolgt vorher eigentlich einen anderen
test machen ob nicht bereits über
ausreichende hat den körper verfügt dann
wenn sie das nicht machen wenn es zu
einer so genannten über ihn vom 4 erst
die nicht habe sagen wir müssten jetzt
vorher alle untersuchen denn ich kann
keine impfstoffe hinten wenn ich nicht
weiß ob der nicht schon einen chinesen
status hat im prinzip oder an eine hohe
anzahl von titeln so dass die impfung
der stadt sogar kontraproduktiv ist ich
hab das marktumfeld also das leben hat
als älteren frauen wo die impfung nicht
durchgenommen eben durchgeführt worden
ist weil sich an der autoimmunkrankheit
hatte weil der test ergeben hat das team
bereits ausreichend geschützt ist ein
durch eine infektion von der sie gar
keine ahnung hatte
völlig richtig man sollte unbedingt die
genesenen ausnehmen von einer ins licht
und man kann heute ein antikörper status
in 24 stunden war der sonst kann man
doch nur noch mal verbrauchen da fragen
wir uns warum wir das nicht gemacht
haben bisher das kann ich auch nicht
beantworten der langst tun so nochmal
zumindest dort bei dem punkt einigkeit
aber nochmal auf die frage ob einmal was
dann passiert also sie wollen diese
menschen dann anschreiben lassen und
diese menschen werden angeschrieben was
ist wenn die sich nicht melden geht es
dann mit bußgeldern weiter und wie sieht
das denn aus ihrer sicht ja gibt zwei
wege die österreicher sagen dann gibt es
halt zufalls kontrollen und wir dann ich
geimpft ist der zahlt dann halt bußgeld
ähnlich wie bei einer verkehrs
übertretung und so würde man es dann
auch machen sie den bußgeldverfahren
einlagen und der bundestag werde
festlegen was dafür der bußgeldrahmen
ist
gut das führt dann auch nichts mehr
hören impfung weil das bußgeld bezahlt
oder auch nicht war viel interessanter
sie daher scharfe anwaltskanzleien in
deutschland beschäftigen ich ja gut für
sie vielleicht herr kubicki ja ich mache
mache mache ich gar nicht so fern bin
auch schon raus also aber ein paar ideal
ihren einspruch ein gegen
bußgeldbescheide die müssen dann zu
amtsgerichten weil das schlusslicht
richter entschieden wenn wir keine
nennenswerte größe auch noch weniger 4 2
bei den über 60-jährigen vielleicht
nicht ganz so dramatisch ab 18 uhr
anderen reden wir über fast 12 über
menschen wenn sie davon nur die hälfte
sich so verhält sich das vermutet dass
sich verhalten wird dann bricht bei uns
das recht zu sehen zu sein
deswegen ist aber 18 wahrscheinlich
wirklich keine gute idee aber noch mal
herr kubicki ich bin jemand der ins
gelingen verliebt ist man kann natürlich
zu jeder lösung problems suchen aber ist
eigentlich nicht ihre erhaltung sonst
diese probleme sind gelöst aber ich kann
wirklich außerdem kann man die wache
trainiert in dieser pandemie paar
materialisiert optisch daraus folgt ja
jetzt nicht das nie wieder was
funktionieren was die kommunen gemacht
haben hat meistens funktioniert ich
glaube wir sollten wirklich
grundsatzfrage ob man die pflicht schon
richtig oder falsch hält klären die
frage der umsetzung ist
nebenkriegsschauplatz wenn man das will
kriegt man das auch ich möchte noch
einmal über die frage sprechen was das
vertrauen in die politik angeht kubicki
da haben sich ja ganz viele politiker in
den vergangenen monaten in den
vergangenen jahren aus dem fenster
gelehnt in allen parteien und haben
gesagt diese im pflicht die wird nicht
kommen was bedeutet das für die menschen
dass sie jetzt das gefühl bekommen ja
was die politiker mal gesagt habe das
gilt jetzt nicht mehr
na gut das problem ist nicht dass das
erklärt worden ist ein besonders ist
apolitisch kreation ist von allen
beteiligten egal was passiert es nicht
geben daraufhin zwang dass diese
differenzierung nicht vorgenommen wir
sind uns alle einig und ich kenne auch
niemanden vernünftigen das ist eine ein
zwang zur impfung also polizei holt die
man von zuhause abschleppdienst und
ordne dagegen das einen solchen 20 geben
wird auch gar nicht ihm kann
verfassungsrechtlich führen wir da alles
dominieren das gemeinwesen bisher
ausgemacht hat aber ich verstehe schon
obwohl ich diese auffassung nicht teile
dass bei einer veränderten datenlage
größer infektiosität von omikron
verstärkte ansteckung auch zu einem
zeitpunkt als der verlauf noch schlimmer
eingeschätzt worden ist wie er jetzt
hoffentlich tatsächlich weiß dass man
dort sagen kann ich ändere in dieser
frage meine haltung meine meinung wäre
nicht festgelegt aber was bei der
gleichen daten komme ich etwas zu
anderen ergebnissen als beispielsweise
meine bundesvorsitzender oder andere
rechnen dass vorsitzende an der gruppe
da möchte ich einmal ein video ihnen
zeigen was vor der wahl aufgenommen
worden ist wie sich christian lindner
zum thema impfpflicht und der frage ob
es dann am ende auch kommt geäußert hat
in einer gesellschaft wo so viele geben
der irgendwie impfte sich wichtig selbst
bewerben deshalb sollen auch im herbst
ungeimpfte zb in die gaststätte gehen
können vielleicht mit der voraussetzung
eines negativen tests denen sie aber
nicht bezahlen müssen wir das macht
sowie darüber sagen sie jetzt sagen sie
das auch noch nach den wahlen das sagen
ich vor den wahlen und nach den wahlen
und 2007 haben sie gesehen dass die fdp
nach den wahlen sogar bereit ist nein zu
sagen zu einer regierung wenn sie dann
zu sagen brechen müsste
klarer wortbruch herr kubicki oder
ja bezogen auf diese politische aussage
ja aber die gleichen aussagen in der
werbung gemacht in einem sie aber jetzt
haben wir bei dem bundesplatz
gebracht eigentlich haben alle diese
aussage vor der bundestagswahl gemacht
immer noch in der anlage dass die
ursprüngliche erklärung des rk ii und
der bundesregierung der alte
bundesregierung werden alle ausreichend
impfstoff zur verfügung haben dann gibt
es keine rechtfertigung mehr farbe
ganzen master wissen das und gern dass
diese aussage geholt wurde das glaube
ich jetzt auch von der einschätzung wir
haben eine böse omikron variante die uns
jetzt komplett überrollt und alles das
wir ist ja gedacht dann aus der kurve
trägt das ist dankenswerterweise nicht
mehr zahlen und ich sage genau so wie
man zum ergebnis konnte ich bin wegen
der befürchtungen was auf uns zukommt
jetzt für eine impfpflicht wenn wir
genauso gut wieder davon runter kommen
die man jetzt feststellt wir sehen so
schlimm wie das wie das erwartete an im
november beispielsweise ist es
dankenswerterweise nicht gekommen
deshalb denken wir darüber nach ich bin
sicher dass wir diese debatte auch
anders als heute in drei oder vier
wochen führen denn wir sehen wenn wir
mehr daten aus anderen ländern und sehen
dass tatsächlich meine einschätzung dass
wir vielleicht doch glücklich sein
können anschließend so viel gelesen
haben gegenüber ähnlichen die bisher
haben dass dann die impfpflicht auch für
die liebsten sie davon aus dass sie
ihren parteivorsitzenden von ihrer
position überzeugen können und er dann
wieder die position einnimmt die er vor
der wahl hatte bei uns und bin so froh
dass wir das bei uns in der fraktion der
partei wirklich ganz offen diskutiert
wird niemand in säcke gestellt weil die
eine oder andere auffassung garten sie
können logischerweise
persönliche erfahrung aufgrund ihrer
vorbilder aufgrund dieser einschätzung
bei der gleichen datenlage zu
unterschiedlicher auffassung kommt
gerade was zukünftig daran geht also ich
kann sagen immer schon gesagt diejenigen
verstehen das kann ich nachvollziehen
die sagen an dem pflicht ab 50 müssen
wir ins werk setzen weil tatsächlich
dann die 90 prozent die momentan dieser
altersgruppe den intensivstationen
belegen reduziert damit das
gesundheitssystem entlastet aber ich
kann auch die marco buschmann jetzt dazu
übergehen und sagen brauchen wir das
wollen auch die medikamente haben ihren
look samt ja nachgewiesen worden ist die
bei einnahme auch dazu beitragen dass
davon 19 stationen kommen müssen das ist
alles im fluss und deshalb gar nicht
davor die eigene position sozusagen als
unser rückwärts zu erklären ich wäre
froh wenn wir zu einer lösung kommen
können mit der die meisten menschen hier
leben können sondern auch befriedet
werden können den glauben sie mir das
ist wenig nicht von spaltung sehen aber
die divergenzen jeder familie eben
sozialen umfeld leben freundeskreis hat
sich das mittlerweile emotional so
aufgeschaukelt das wird darauf zu
deeskalation beitragen das sind genau
über diese spaltung wollen wir nach der
werbung sprechen es gibt forderungen
dass zum beispiel das arbeitslosen
geschnitten werden soll für ungeimpfte
und die problematik in den pflegeheimen
das ist das thema nach der werbung
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem
duell zu impfpflicht zwischen wolfgang
kubicki und boris palmer herr palmer es
gibt einen vorschlag oder eine analyse
von detlef scheele chef der
bundesagentur für arbeit der sagt falls
eine impfpflicht gegen korona kommt
könnten arbeitgeber fortan ungeimpfte
bewerber ablehnen also das
arbeitslosengeld könnte wegfallen geht
das alles nicht langsam mit viel zu weit
was ihr passiert
kindern vorschlag ich kann ihnen auch
rechtlich nicht bewerten aber ich halte
ihn jedenfalls inhaltlich falsch wenn
ich vertrete wie dargestellt dann weil
ich alle anderen corona verbote
loswerden möchte und auch nicht dadurch
neue
unterscheidungen schaffen will im
gegenteil ich bin sogar der meinung wie
herr kubicki dass die 2g regel und diese
diversen benachteiligung und der
ungeimpften und zuletzt auch die
chinesen in die verkürzung des genesenen
status hat soweit ich sehe keinerlei
empirische grundlage dass dieses
drängender leute zur impfung in dem man
nachteile
meinen verschafft dass das eher
kontraproduktiv ist und ich finde das
sollten wir wirklich lassen noch mal
meine aussage ist eine einzige regel das
sind geimpft und an der anderen regeln
sollten weg herr kubicki wie verrückt
ist das in england feiern die menschen
wieder auch in dänemark masken weg und
bei uns reden wir über eine impfpflicht
und gleichzeitig ich wiederhole noch mal
sagt detlef scheele die impfpflicht
könnte konsequenzen haben für den
arbeitsmarkt arbeitgeber könnten
ungeimpfte und nicht gewesene bewerber
ablehnen und ich zitiere das sei möglich
wenn es eine allgemeine impfpflicht gibt
und verstöße auch mit rechts folgen
verbunden sind
die sind natürlich in den gehirnen der
bundesagentur für arbeit raten bei
seinen leisten zu bleiben er ist kein
arbeitsrechtlich ist auch keine kanzlei
teils aber es wird die erklärung abgeben
kann ich finde dass unverfroren der
jetzigen phase mit solchen ankündigungen
oder solchen anregungen zu kommen vor
allen dingen weil das wie ich glaube die
wut derjenigen die sich überlegen unter
umständen morgen dort nochmal zur
impfung zu gehen er steigern wird das
nicht zu tun weil diese diese zumutung
dass man menschen alpha den senkel
gestellt auf kunden des impfstatus weil
diese zu mittlerweile für mich
unerträglich werden noch einmal gefahr
geht ja nicht von ungeimpften aus
sondern von infizierten und da wir
wissen dass auch die impfte und gepostet
der sich genauso infizieren können die
ungeimpfte ist dieser vorschlag zu
differenzieren und nach unten zu ergeben
sei es kontraproduktiv da müssen wir
sagen wer sich infiziert verliert sein
amt vor auf arbeitslosengeld weil er
seine arbeitskraft zur verfügung stellen
können und dann sind da wird der schädel
sofort erkennen dass er komplett offen
sind ist herr palmer wie gefährlich ist
das klima momentan auf der einen seite
geimpfte ungeimpfte die wut aufeinander
die politik gehe immer weiter diskutiert
macht ihnen das angst
ich hatte sorgen letzte woche sind
spaziergänger von meinem wohnhaus
gekommen und habe ein paar immer vorweg
gerufen aus der menge das ist jetzt
nicht was man erleben möchte im privaten
umfeld gebe ich ihnen schon recht auf
der anderen seite sehe ich aber eine
gewisse entspannung denn auch bei mir
ist es so dass ich jetzt leichter damit
leben kann wenn es nicht zu ängstlich
kommt dann erkennbar ist dass omikron
nicht die schweren folgen für unsere
gesellschaft haben wird die man
jedenfalls im november oder dezember
wegen der riesigen zahlen durchaus mit
grund befürchten konnte ich glaube man
kann jetzt wirklich eine abwägungsfrage
man kann sich für oder gegen die
impfpflicht entscheiden ich finde der
kubicki hat sehr respektabel der
argumente gegen die impfpflicht
vorgetragen dass bleiben weiterhin auch
gute gründe für die impfpflicht der
druck ist raus weil nicht mehr so viel
dampf im kessel ist ich habe jetzt nicht
mehr die sorge dass morgen alles
zusammenbricht weil der bundestag das
nicht schafften impfpflicht zu
beschließen sehen wie ich da jetzt auch
zurückhaltender und sagt ich habe immer
noch gute gründe dafür aber ich kann
auch damit leben wenn es nicht so kommt
aber sie sagen der dampf ist raus was
macht das mit ihnen wenn der menschen
vor dem wohnhaus stehen und timer
verrecke brüllen sind dass die leute die
sie angreifen weil sie eben für diese
impfpflicht geworben haben ja eindeutig
es war ein spaziergänger mit kerzen und
ohne masken da gab es kein zweifel und
ist dann in obhut entstanden weil sie
eben prominent dafür jetzt eintreten für
diese impfpflicht das war auch im
internet sehr klar zu spüren wir dass
ich für die impfpflicht eingesetzt zeit
wurde mit faschismus
vergleichen belegt ich habe übels
karikaturen mit ich sei auch ein jude
und tatsächlich jüdische vorfahren der
jetzt hier an der weltverschwörung
arbeitet alles gesehen das ist ganz übel
aber leider kehrt das internet auch
nicht unbedingt die besten seiten der
menschen nach draußen das ist wohl
richtig
weimar und
ich wollte nur sagen also ist es nicht
nur bedauerlich sei es aber skandalös
dass er uns in deutschland nicht
eingewöhnt haben vernünftig wenn er zu
diskutieren sondern das sofort
eingeordnet wird in die kategorie noch
nicht bekommen mord und todesdrohung
interessanterweise weil ich gegen meine
ich bin nachhaltig sei jetzt für
hunderttausende von toten verantwortlich
habe überhaupt
aber das ist gar nicht mal criteo also
ein kriterium ist dass wir dass wir
aufhören müssen in gut und böse
einzuteilen dass wir aufhören müssen an
der aktualität zu zweifeln die
90 fast 100-prozentig die für eine
inflation machen dass er nicht aus dass
unter weil sie menschen ärgern wollen
sondern weil sie wirklich sorge haben
wir ja auch wenn die ich nachvollziehen
kann ich muss das nicht teilen aber ich
kann es nachvollziehen ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir uns an gebühren würden
wieder zunächst einmal auf das zu hören
was andere sagen ohne ihn gleich
schlimme dinge zu unterstellen beide
linien die glauben dass bill gates der
microsoft schon nicht richtig auf die
reihe bekommen also das eine ist ein
chip anfangs will um die weltwirtschaft
zu erleben dem ist nicht zu helfen denn
das auch entsprechend mit muskeln nicht
zu helfen aber ich finde ich sehe das
auch im sozialen umfeld wir können alle
ob für ihn pflicht über gegen
impfpflicht alle noch dafür werben dass
leute sich impfen das sind ich erkläre
immer wieder ich habe mir bereits einen
weiteren termin geben lassen ohne zu
wissen ob die vierte impfung überhaupt
möglich ist weil ich einfach meine
innere freiheit behalten will nicht
angst haben zu müssen von menschen
infiziert hin dass ich auf sie treffen
das ist ein großer vorteil der einfach
nicht ich muss als die impfte und
infizierten keine angst mehr haben und
das ist das gute und wenn das alle bild
das man haben da ist der schritt für
einige wenige doch noch und dann
erreichen wir vielleicht die 80 prozent
von der urlaub stolz worden das ja doch
noch menschen davon überzeugen und wir
können auch mit unseren kampagnen
wirklich kreativer sein das ist ja
gerade das neue image-kampagne für 60
millionen sehe das zieht ein wirklich
spur aus da kann ich nur sagen wenn ihr
so diaz kann kann die gemachten er denn
nie jemand von dünger gekauft
die große die große frage oder die große
debatte beim thema impfen ist ja vor
allem bei denjenigen die jetzt in
krankenhäusern arbeiten in pflegeheimen
arbeiten und da haben wir in dieser
woche einen stellvertretenden landrat
aus bautzen gehört der sehr sehr
emotional war schauen wir uns das einmal
an
sie mich danach fragen was das
gesundheitsamt des landkreises bautzen
machen wird ab dem 16 dritten dann
werden wir unser gesundheitsamt unseren
mitarbeitern im landkreis bautzen im
pflegerischen bereich kein berufsverbot
betretungsverboten
kubicki riesenjubel über diese aussage
der vize landrat hat den vorwurf mit dem
berufsverbot zurückgenommen aber er
bleibt dabei dass für ihn die sicherung
der pflege von kranken und alten vorrang
hat vor der durchsetzung der impfpflicht
hat er nicht recht
ja zunächst einmal ist die öffentliche
äußerung bewerben uns an gesetzliche
regeln nicht kontraproduktiv
selbstverständlich bleibt es den
gesundheitsämtern nach der regelung
getroffen haben bitte einrichtung
gezogen endlich angenommen in 1 derzeit
zu entscheiden was auch umgeben steht in
der pflege tätig bleiben können wenn
ansonsten die strukturen zusammenbrechen
würden was in einigen bundesländern in
deutschlands osten mit sicherheit ein
größeres problem ist als in vielen
bereichen in deutschlands besten
aber wir müssen uns ja auch die frage
stellen die jetzt dort arbeiten haben
sich zwei jahre nicht angesteckt und
haben ihre ihre arbeit ausüben können
was mal ist in der welt wirst uns
glauben dass sie weniger vorsichtig um
sich zu infizieren damit auf andere zu
infizieren entscheidend ist für mich
dass die ihren einrichtungen sind
gepolstert werden möglichst schnell das
sind ja
in der regel tag den menschen und wenn
ich jetzt höre da ist eine ganze reihe
von pflegeeinrichtungen gibt in dem die
buchung ist ja auch nicht vollzogen
worden ist weil es das zentrale problem
er kann damit sicher zu stellen bei die
menschen extrem gefährdet sind aber ich
kann nachvollziehen dass
leute aus ihrem beruf ausscheiden das
zeichen aus meiner sicht dass die
impfpflicht im zweifel bei denen auch
nicht wirken wird wer seinen beruf liebt
jetzt aufgebe das nicht impfen lassen
der wird sich auch im muskel bescheid
dazu bewegen lassen dass wir vielleicht
auch hier
intensive malen uns mit der situation
beschäftigen müssen was passiert
vgh hat heute gesagt die wirte auch
diejenigen die sich infiziert haben den
kritischen der infrastruktur weiter
arbeiten lassen wollen denn die
abgeschirmt sind vor anderen also wenn
man auf eine regel stationen eines
kraftwerks sitzen alle sind infiziert
aber sollte ich ja nicht auch
miteinander gemeinsam weiterarbeiten wir
werden uns bezogen und situationsbezogen
tatsächlich anders herangehen müssen als
wir uns als im deutschen bundestag bei
der debatte gedacht haben weil es wie
gesagt ich höre dass immer wieder gerade
in sachsen anhalt thüringen auch bei der
mobilen betreuung von älteren menschen
probleme geben würde mit diesem mobilen
kräfte aus weil es dafür keinen ersatz
und was wir nicht wollen könnt ist das
jetzt menschen die hilfe brauchen die
hilfe nicht mehr bekommen weil die
entsprechenden menschen fehlen denn wir
wollen sie jetzt wegen sich impfen
lassen wenn sich das nicht wollen
scheiden sie aus lässt liegt dann kann
ersetzt tod uns einen pflegenotstand
bosbach
die zahl der ebenen die nicht geimpft
sind im gesundheitswesen im
pflegebereich sehr klein nach meiner
kenntnis bei uns unter fünf prozent in
thüringen wir haben probleme bei der
versorgung in sachsen sind 100.000 von
300.000 zb es mag sein ich kann nur über
die hiesige situation sprechen die
differenzierung ist sicher richtig also
bei uns wird deswegen kein notstand
ausbrechen aber ich will da auf den
umstand hinweisen der hier wieder mit
den daten und den voraussetzungen zu tun
hat ich finde was der stellvertretende
landrat dort gemacht hat geht nicht man
kann keine rede ans volk halten dass man
gesetze nicht beachten will das geht
wirklich nicht man kann briefe an
bundestagsabgeordnete oder regierungen
schreiben dass regeln falsch sind das
mache ich öfter mal weil es gibt auch
falsche regeln so was kommt vor aber
hier ist es ja so dass die impfpflicht
für diese beschäftigten beschlossen
wurde als wir noch davon ausgehen
konnten zwar delta zeit dass es ein
schutz vor infektionen gibt durch die
impfung das heißt dass man auch weniger
gefahr für die personen bedeutet die man
pflegt
genau diese voraussetzung ist ja
entfallen das heißt für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht gibt es aus den gründen ich
würde ihn nicht wiederholen durchaus
noch eine rechtfertigung auch schon eine
spezielle impfpflicht dieser
personengruppe gibt es eigentlich keine
rechtfertigung mehr weil die
schutzwirkung gegenüber den trick
gepflegten personen gefallen ist und das
ist finde ich die schwierigkeiten in der
da die gesetzgebung steckt eigentlich
ist sie jetzt wieder hinderte pandemie
und müsst ihr darauf reagieren und ihre
regeln anpassen an omikron hat sie aber
nicht getan
das heißt diese studie nicht immer
ausdrücklich zu dass die letzte woche
berichtet ausgewiesen dass ihr bei der
hospitalisierung mehr gemustert und die
ängste haben was umgehend für das genau
darauf hindeutet dass die frage der
inspektion die gesagt vom impfstatus gar
nicht abhängt und die argumentation war
tatsächlich die in gesundheitsberufen
sollen gewissen damit sie
anderen nicht mehr anstecken können die
sie betreuen und pflegen wenn das
wegfällt weil der impfstoff das eben
nicht macht weil sie bei freuen sich
auch infizieren können dann fällt eine
der tragenden grundlagen für diese in
pflicht also wieder aufheben der gruppe
g
na jedenfalls würde ich dann den
gesundheitsämtern vor ort ist ja die
unterschiedlich den ganzen tag vor ort
sagen sie sollten von der möglichkeit
die entscheidungen zu treffen nach
situation dass man die dann dass er ja
intensive und nicht glaubt von der
gesetzgeber eine generelle pflicht
verordnet hat müsste die auch in diesem
fall umgesetzt also was schlimmer wäre
wäre das schließen von einrichtungen des
nicht mehr versorgung von älteren
menschen in
ostdeutschland ist sein ist das
derzeitig hulot von quoten bei
zahnärzten von 40 prozent ihre praxen zu
machen würde damit sein als die
versorgung schlicht und ergreifend
wieder laufen würden und auch einmal für
mich ist auch die mobile pflege ein ganz
wenige argumente wenn eine immobilie
gesagt ausfällt dann wären acht oder
zehn menschen nicht mehr versorgt und
wenn keine alternative dafür besteht
haben wir ein riesenproblem das müssen
die gesagt die gesundheitsämter in zwei
vor ort richtig
vernünftig pragmatisch entscheiden japan
war sollte man die impfpflicht für
pflege heimat für pflegekräfte wieder
aufheben
meine antwort ist ja man sollte die
allgemeine impfpflicht für die
risikogruppe einführen das heißt wenn
die pflegekraft älter als fünfzig wäre
wäre sie betroffen wäre sie jünger
könnte man meiner meinung nach darauf
verzichten weil der schutz vor
infektionen bei uns dann nicht mehr
gegeben ist klare antwort zu der frage
was hier passieren soll wenn wir uns
jetzt ankommen anschauen er kubicki was
in der bundespolitik gerade zwischen
lauterbach und anderen los ist wo es um
die frage geht was den genesenen status
angeht das robert-koch-institut eigen
mäßig darüber entschieden wie lange
menschen als chinesen gelten und damit
eben auch ob sie ins restaurant gehen
oder ohne test bus und bahn fahren
dürfen hat lka-chef wieder da zu viel
gemacht
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wie
gesagt gegen seit 32 jahren politisch
tätig ich kann mir wirklich nicht
vorstellen dass eine solche entscheidung
bundeswehr jetzt hoffen wird mit
auswirkungen auch millionen von menschen
ohne rückkopplung des dafür ist er jetzt
das wird muss noch geklärt werden aber
das berliner oder wie auch immer in dem
einfach die internetseite ändert und wir
dann die genesener status halbieren ist
für mich schwer nachvollziehbar vor
allen dingen gehört das nicht zu seiner
kompetenz die em zweite baum kann der
palma schon darauf hingewiesen dass es
tatsächlich keine wissenschaftliche
evidenz dafür gibt dass der genesene
staates gekürzt werden muss es gibt eine
evidenz dafür dass der gti ist dann
starb mindestens genauso lange andauern
kann wie der impfstatus und das wird das
größte in dieses nächste größere problem
im karl lauterbach möchte europäischer
ebene gegen erstattung 30 reduzieren die
ich kenne kein anderes land mittlerweile
und ich höre schon ablehnende bescheide
aus dänemark aus großbritannien aus
italien aus spanien wo die leute sagen
wir verstehen uns gar nicht mehr dass
jeder gerade getan eigentlich wenn über
eine verstaubte auf zehn monate
ausweiten schwarzer noch so eben heute
ausgebeutet weil noch dran wechsel zu
reduzieren und es gibt einen grundsatz
wir dürfen in europa keinen sonderweg in
dieser frage weil das ja alles
grenzüberschreitung passiert ist es doch
geradezu r trennen lässt der geschichte
es mit den genesenen status suchen heute
nach spanien urlaub fahren kann aber den
genesenen staus treffen weil ich an
deutschland zurückkehren kann ohne eine
weitere testung oder eine weiteren an
weiteren kriegsmann oberen wolftal wird
lothar wieler zur belastung für karl
lauterbach und die ampel oder bin ich
jetzt will ich nicht zuständig aber ich
kann mir auch klar äußern zu der frage
ob es richtig war diese verkürzung
vorzunehmen das sage ich jetzt als
bürger und stadtoberhaupt ich denke es
geht nicht dass man von einem tag auf
den anderen den status verliert auf den
man sich verlassen hat und ja zum
beispiel notwendig ist um dann einkaufen
zu dürfen so war es ja letzte woche noch
oder ins restaurant gehen zu können das
kann nicht über nacht passieren das kann
ich über eine internetseite passieren
und eigentlich halte ich das für eine
politische entscheidung und nicht eine
entscheidung die das lka autonomen
treffen kündete erwarte ich schon dass
die politik abwägt weil es sind
eindeutig folgen die weit über die
medizinische frage hinaus geht und noch
mal schon die uni tübingen hat vor einem
jahr eine studie veröffentlicht die sagt
aufgrund der tc immunität sind genesene
besser geschützt als geimpfte und das
gilt wohl bis heute für alle studien die
vorliegen dann kann man doch nicht in
genießen den status viel kürzer halten
als den der impfung das erweckt den
eindruck als würde es hier nicht nach
vernünftigen kriterien entschieden und
das ist etwas wo ich finde da muss man
sehr vorsichtig sein also jedenfalls
finde ich diese entscheidung nicht
nachvollziehbaren würde mir auch
wünschen dass aufgeklärt und wie sie
zustande gekommen ist wie kann man das
am besten aufklären und da vertrauen
zurückzugewinnen bei den bürgern das war
es nur herr kubicki der ist abgeordneter
ich bin da nicht der richtige begriff
was würdet ihr tun ich möchte mich
wichtig ich möchte nun der
unionsfraktion da kann ich keine tipps
wie man sowas aufklären kann aber es ist
mit sicherheit so dass man zumindest
also karl lauterbach und und herren
wieder so ganz ausschuss des deutschen
bundestages mag sagen sollte die beiden
ligen
gleichzeitig sind sagen sich hinsetzen
lassen sollte muss er wieder drehen
dann komm ich weiß dass das für die bild
-zeitung ganz wichtig ist für
schlagzeilen zu produzieren aber ich
glaube dass wenn fehler passiert sind
immer leicht da muss irgendwie mal gehen
uns nicht weiter erst einmal
fehlerbeseitigung ist das zentrale sie
kennen ja mal eine ohnehin schon sehr
skeptisch was das galli insgesamt angeht
ich verstehe nicht nach wie vor nicht
dass ihr deutschland viel stärker
industrienationen der welt nach zwei
jahren immer noch günstige datenlage
haben dass wir nach das einzige land das
keine vernünftigen der untersuchung auf
sorgen jeweils wir stützen uns dauernd
auf israelische auch für britische auf
technische studien hat man selbst
welches zu unternehmen da gibt es eine
ganz weil von vorschlägen wir dem ein
schweinegeld aus für diese ganze im
verein teams kampagne aber ich
verbessere mich unseren datenlage und
zielgenau operieren zu können das ist
das was mich nach und wir haben in der
koalitionsvereinbarung ja vereinbart
dass genau das hat besser werden soll
und ich erwarte ihr von carlotta sie
wissen ja gern ein angespannt ist aber
trotzdem sehr gutes verhältnis
zueinander dass die diskussionslage
angeht ich erwarte von karl lauterbach
dass das jetzt endlich umgesetzt wird
dass wir unsere lage verbessern
sicherlich der ort in delhi steuern
müssen herr palmer wenn wir uns
anschauen den aktuellen
bundesgesundheitsminister wir haben in
der vergangenheit viel immer über den
spann gesprochen auch mit ihnen hierbei
bild live lauterbach ist jetzt eine
weile im amt wie fällt ihre bilanz aus
ich bin ehrlich gesagt überrascht ich
habe ihn zwei jahre in talkshows erlebt
manchmal dass ich dabei und er hat sich
immer für die jeweils schlechteste
variante entschieden das düsterste bild
gemalt und daraus dann die immer
härtesten konsequenzen abgeleitet immer
wieder locker und kontakt beschränkung
gefordert und ich bin ehrlich sagt
völlig verblüfft sei der minister ist
ist er völlig anders und sagt uns zum
beispiel vor weihnachten kein lockt ein
notwendig es scheint so zu sein dass die
fdp sehr starken einfluss auf ihn
gewonnen hat den herr buschmann hat ja
in einem interview zur echten
gedankenspiel aufgemacht unser
justizminister das ist schon links
wieder lockt angegeben hätte wie die
alte regierung noch im amtszeit findet
es einen interessanten gedanken wie viel
einfluss haben sie auf ein lauterbacher
kubicki also sie persönlich vielleicht
aber das ganze andere war ihnen in der
fdp machen die ihm so viel druck dass er
jetzt anders politik macht
inhaltlich kann gegangen
kanada haben sich verteidigen denn ist
einer der wenigen der sehr offen
diskutieren auch sehr reflektiert aber
er muss eben einfach zu sagen dass er
aus dieser wissenschafts computer heraus
musste er ist jetzt in entscheidungs
community er ist jetzt minister und er
muss das ist ein persönlicher rate ich
ihm auch schon gegeben habe nicht alles
alleine machen wollen das wasser einmal
auf als oberbürgermeister alles alleine
machen will dann steht man irgendwann
neue vorgehen von großen bergen die man
nicht mehr hat nicht mehr allein
bewältigen können aber das trio riten
auch setzen für mich geht das er jetzt
erklären muss wir bauen das werk nie so
um dass wir mit den aussagen des
wissenschaftlers anfangen können oder
dass die sich an die stelle des
gesetzgebers ist als verordnungsgeber
setzen dass wir endlich wieder grund
unter die füße bekommen irgendwann
findet viele richtung zu marschieren
aber angeben sie geben sie aber damit
geben sie ihm wie eine andere auch noch
ein bisschen zeit der ist ins kalte
wasser gesprungen
sie brauchen etwas zeit dass wir auch
mal die behörde zu strukturieren zu
organisieren das ist jetzt sechs wochen
ehe oder acht wochen her dass diese
regierung wenn wir weihnachten
rauslassen sechs wochen im amt ist die
sind auch beim boarding und langsam wird
es zeit das ist bowling abgeschlossen
wird und wenn man abhebt zu
bessere ziel jetzt ist ja lauterbacher
wahnsinnig beliebt momentan beliebtester
minister das war jetzt sparen auch mal
der ist dann abgestürzt was nicht
interessiert herr kubicki was sagen denn
die leute in ihrer stammkneipe in
strande mittlerweile über karl
lauterbach
kann lauter war es interessanterweise
nicht mehr das gesprächsthema wie früher
weil er etwas wenig ein torschuss
auftauchen und jetzt auch nicht mehr bei
meister angesprochen nicht mehr als der
defekt ist der nation wird die gegend
läuft weil alle deutsche auftritt von
karl lauterbach gedacht haben wenn das
virus in unsere verstärkt wäre so aber
es ist tatsächlich
man wundert sich insgesamt das betrifft
mich ja auch gesagt kommen was macht ihr
da eigentlich in berlin man wundert sich
insgesamt würde ich die diskussionslage
die welt gegenwärtig haben wenn man sich
wahrscheinlich sein ist ja nah an den
beiden anderen ländern ist dann sieht
man die haben die gleichen probleme sind
aber nicht ganz so pessimistisch was
ihre lebenseinstellung angeht und die
zukunft angeht und man wünscht sich
selbst sagte einmal wir alle wünschen
was so dass man wieder wieder lachen
können und das gefühl haben können wir
haben jedenfalls ein bisschen tags des
normalen lebens soll herr palmer wann
können wir wieder lachen abschlussrunde
basten weg clubs auf wir hören auf über
kroner nachzudenken wann glauben sie
könnte dass endlich der fall sein
beschaulich auf nachbarländer
in den beiden letzten jahren war es ja
so dass das früher immer eine zeit war
in der wir wieder lachen kunden da bin
ich sehr optimistisch ich denke dass wir
im april spätestens mai die pandemie
weitgehend hinter uns lassen können ich
hoffe dass es auch ohne impfpflicht
gelingen kann vielleicht gelingt es auch
so aber mit ihm pflicht wäre ich
zuversichtlicher dass es im nächsten
winter nicht wieder maßnahmen gebaut
herr kubicki wie schnell glauben sie
wenn sie wieder hier das tun was ihnen
spaß macht oder denken sie müssen noch
mal nach dänemark segeln um die freiheit
in dem moment in dem moment in dem die
erste meldung nicht heißt dass wir
wieder steigende tendenzen haben oder
vor krankenhäusern
und ich glaube die hat einmal auch das
wird schneller kommen als wie das
momentan befürchten oder hoffen denn die
welle tatsächlich im mittel februar
gestattet sein wird wenn die zahlen sehr
schnell da unten gehen werden das jetzt
sehen wir aus anderen ja auch dann wird
sich der fokus der menschen wieder mehr
auf ihr tägliches leben berichten da ist
auf die frage wie kann ich mit der angst
der sorge und der gefahr umgehen welche
öffnung kann jetzt schnell kommen gibt
ja bald wieder im pkw opel
zweig plus umsehen denn noch einmal
zweig bedeutet die beute müssen alle
geimpft sei und 2g plus wenn deutliche
schützen jetzt geben wir vorgeben was ja
angesichts der opencom bei der ich schon
keinen sinn also das ist nonsens gelesen
thema bei den fck raus damit das wäre
eine meiner forderung mit wir können
auch zweig waren einkaufen bett lassen
wenn wir wir wissen ja das meiste dann
in dem spieler ist gar kein
infektionsketten gekommen ist warum die
leute an masken getragen hat eingehalten
das können sie neben anderen geschäft
genauer geschäft genauso organisieren
also dass während der nächste punkt und
ich würde immer noch empfehlen
persönlich zum selbstschutz jedenfalls
in geschlossenen räumen oder über oder
s-bahn in der gp2 und was wir zu tragen
weil das mit sicherheit ein riesen
schutz gegen die infektion die
mittlerweile aber den masken nervte
meisten der region in london ist die
welt wirklich wirklich wirklich masken
pflicht auch nicht andere sagen leute
zum
selbstmord im winter nachtrag masken und
dann habt ihr demnächst eine sorge
weniger also keine pflicht mehr sondern
eigene verantwortung für die menschen
die sagen will soll sie tragen so was
ist aber wenn das eine idee
die maske würde ich jetzt werden sie
wirklich wenig schaden anrichtet und
vielen jetzt erstmal noch lassen aber
ich stelle mir auch zu wir sollten
zurückgehen zu 3g damit alle wieder
teilhaben können der schutz ist gerade
so gut wie zweig seit neben der
infektionsschutz nicht mehr gegeben ist
die konnten mich sorgen vor allem die
schulen weil da haben wir jetzt so eine
art schließung durch die hintertür weil
immer mehr klassen geschlossen werden
wenn dazu viele fälle auftreten ich
würde eigentlich dazu übergehen dass man
nur noch kinder mit symptomen nach hause
geschickt und ist im torlosen einfach
zur schule gehen lässt denn lernen ist
für unsere kinder wichtiger als
symptomlos infektionen nachzujagen
herzlichen danke ich ausdrücklich
herzlichen dank boris palmer herzlichen
dank wolfgang kubicki für die spannende
debatte hierzu impfpflicht heute abend
bei die richtigen fragen machen sie es
gut
[Musik]